so in the cutest [ __ ] ever he gets his
little preschool backpack
starts stuffing it with his toys right
cause he's gonna leave and go live
outside
this isn't the dead of winter in korea
it's cold as [ __ ] so my mom
looks at him she goes oh you think this
is your stuff that's my stuff
she rips the backpack off of them strips
him butt naked i'm talking about
balls out baby dick out everything right
[ __ ] kicks him out leaves him in
front of the door of the house
locks the door right and my mom said
like your brothers
in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of the covet free
genius brain podcast i just took my test
thank you for the at-home test yeah so i
bought a bunch of uh
at in-home tests so anybody who comes in
to the podcast now has to take a test
it's very simple it's fast it takes
about 15 minutes but
gives me a peace of mind specifically
because of the holidays right now so i
know people are going to leave so i want
to make sure that everybody's okay
i take the test quite frequently my
[ __ ] nose has no sensation in it
how's your taste uh my taste is like 50
back
and then the my sense of smell i found
out my sense of smell came back because
i farted
that was like the worst way i found out
i couldn't smell anything and then
something smelled rancid and i'm like
oh i farted that's me yeah
and i was a little relieved that i could
[ __ ] smell my fart yeah
that was a weird thing because you know
i was talking about this on the podcast
with my buddy gabo
and i think the the thing that i kind of
started to realize
too and i kind of got it before was just
the idea that
a lot of people who don't care about
cobit they're seeing it from
a very narrow point of view of i'm young
everybody's going to get it so who the
[ __ ] cares no foresight yeah there's no
foresight on it
about a virus that most people don't
know what the side effects are so for
example i was just talking about it with
ed
uh i found out that a friend of mine um
they hot coved and they had memory loss
what the [ __ ]
you know you know can't remember [ __ ]
so i mean that wasn't a part of the the
typical list of kovid right and that's
not what he was expecting
uh somebody else recently we found out
through our buddy nick that he has a
friend who actually just passed away
from it
and didn't i don't know that she didn't
have like underlying conditions but she
just had a kid so her immune system or
whatever was shot
uh four kids now doesn't have a mom
exactly so like you know when when
people kind of have this idea of well
i'm young i should be able to survive it
it's like well the thing is nobody knows
what happens with kova yet
there's new things that are being found
found out about it every day we just
found out that there's a new strand
coming from europe so and it's like the
the uh the efficacy of how fast it
spreads is like 70
or some [ __ ] it's way more vicious than
than the current one that we have right
now
it's inevitable right yeah like when
when i found out you had it and then
like all the [ __ ] coming down and dan
said there was like the record number of
cases in a day a couple of days ago i
just felt like
the walls are closing in on me like it's
gonna happen yeah because i'm just gonna
get it you know and when i had it too
when i was in that room i
[ __ ] was going to lose my mind yeah
and it only took about one day
because i'm not it's it's that idea of
your freedom not being there and
yeah i i'm not in shackles i could
technically leave but i'm not going to
be that [ __ ] that has kova that's
going to walk through a hotel and give
it to somebody
that's not going to be me did you think
about
what if i die alone do you think about
that no i didn't think that
you did it okay if i ever catch up
okay don't take bad thoughts that's just
me like i'm already like [ __ ] being
self-destructive and [ __ ]
man what i did think about though
was like uh people in prison that's the
first thing i thought about
i thought about people in prison and
being in solitude whoever's in solitary
confinement or people who are just
locked up in a cage
and how terrible that feels the idea
that your freedom is stripped the way
that you can't leave
on your own volition made me
lose my mind i think that was this this
is probably the
first encounter of depression i've ever
had in my life yeah and it felt very uh
defeating so now i could actually say i
know what depression feels like
hope is lost like this could be it or
whatever exactly
and so when there was a point when i was
sitting in the room and i just remember
i teared up she started tearing up it's
just
me by myself and then you know this
heater doesn't work
exactly i just sat there and i started
tearing up
i was like yo man this sucks yeah you
know and then
i kind of snapped out of it i was like
well you know you can't leave you know
you are paying for this hotel room
you're being kind of a
[ __ ] but just the idea of being alone
and then uh not being able to walk
outside and do norm because i
i typically now bike every day yeah i
haven't since because i'm still not
like 100 physically there i i still get
fatigued
um pretty easy and that's the only
remainder side effect and then
now most of my taste is back and then uh
now most of my smell is bad as well
according to the fart so well
just to take it back so you said this
guy lost his memory right
how long uh i think it's still there's
like a fat chunk of it that's still gone
it hasn't come back this is like he just
like woke up one day
like did hillary win
so what's happening four years guys that
should have been so funny what i was
sick
what are you talking about what did i
get he goes why do they have a [ __ ]
celebrity apprentice guy up there
he's like that's the press of the united
states bro why is the game show host the
president
black panther what's that
yeah but it sucks because who knows
what's gonna happen with this virus
right now
and i and i feel you know like the new
perspective that i got to was like
there's
there's other things aside from just
dying from this virus that
is seems to be more i don't say more not
more dangerous but it's just
it's a danger that a lot of people don't
think about the mental health aspect of
it
right being away in isolation um
and by the way it's not a [ __ ] walk
in the park i had what we call mild
symptoms but that [ __ ] [ __ ] sucked
like there was a typically when i get a
headache or i have a fever if i take
tylenol it a good amount of it
dissipates
tylenol nothing wasn't doing [ __ ] so i
just had to deal with the headache
and the pain and all that [ __ ] it was a
weird headache too like i can't
describe it but it was a really really
sharp pain and i i just had a certain
point i remembered one of my friends in
high school who um
there was two people so my brother had a
friend in high school who had an
aneurysm and his
um so an aneurysm is when your blood
vessel pops in your head or some [ __ ]
right and so he was having these crazy
headaches and so
you know like i think like with asian
americans they were trying to give him
like traditional asian medicine or
whatever but they didn't realize
how severe his situation was right and
i'm pretty sure this kid was going
through a lot of mental issues as well
but he like from the excruciating pain
from the
from his head and everything else from
him from having his aneurysm and
his mental health in his mental
situation he actually killed himself
so he uh he shot himself in the head and
he killed himself you know
those are the thoughts that came to mind
no here's the thing when you say
aneurysm is just like that
i know so many korean parents like my
friend's parents who died of brain
aneurysms
yeah and i thought you were going to go
there i was like damn another korean
oh
yeah and then my one of my other close
friends he had an aneurysm in high
school
um and i remember he had to get his head
shaved but my friends are so [ __ ]
goofy because i didn't know what an
aneurysm is and i had to ask around what
it was and they said like a blood vessel
popped in his head right and so they had
to
you know he had to go through surgery
they had to fix that little vein in his
head or whatever
um some doctors out there like this guy
got it completely wrong yeah
this is from what i remember in high
school but i remember because i walked
up to him and we were in the hospital
and i don't like hospitals but just
seeing him in the hospital just all
[ __ ] up
and i remember uh this whole asked me if
i could feed him something i think it
was like a pudding cup or some [ __ ]
he was like hey man like it's like i'm
really hungry can you feed me and i was
like cool
i was like yeah man like we're all sad
and [ __ ] and i take the spoon and i put
in his mouth and i feed him and then he
goes
you're my [ __ ] i just feel like sedated
like he just got out of surgery [ __ ]
got me got
like giggling half awake like this will
[ __ ] fed me some pudding hey
what a friend yeah speaking of
friends yeah yeah so we um
last time we went over uh a very very
very fun film called mulan
which some people got really upset at
the the our opinions or critiques of the
film
right and it's funny because i kind of
got into it with one person because he
was just saying like oh if i was in a
room with these two people
i could probably counter every single
one of the things i'm like if you're in
a room
what the [ __ ] are you talking about guys
this is just our opinion of the film
thanks for letting us know about your
fantasies bro
it was so funny just listening to what
he was saying and then his points
weren't valid at all
you know he was like i forgot i can't
even remember but it was
it was something ridiculous right he
wasn't even picking out the points that
we were saying which i'm fine if you
like the film that's dope like i'm glad
you liked it
doesn't you're not going to change my
mind though we're just some two
just two dudes we're just two dudes man
don't saw a movie
were you the [ __ ] director you cut
back like shut the [ __ ] up
uh hey he must honor right i forgot did
i not honor your family yeah he's
another
my culture i know son of a [ __ ] but i
thought it'd be really fun
and we haven't done this on the podcast
before but um i always talk about how
much i love
korean cinema right so in the
conversation when we talk about asian
american films
or asian films in general people always
say you know we're waiting for these
um a lot of asian talent to come out but
in our minds i'm like bro there have
been great asian films
yeah have you seen and guess who has
them netflix amazon all of them hulu
they got them all
they're all over the place and one of
the films that i that i love growing up
was this film called
chingu chingo means friend in korean so
if you guys don't know about this film
this is like
the pinnacle of korean gangster films
right this is like the korean godfather
and goodfellas in one right it's
actually i watched this film three times
during quarantine
because ed texted me he's like dude they
have ching on amazon
it's funny because when i started when i
watch it now from uh
you know because we're older now when i
watch it it hits a little harder right
you know the camaraderie the friendship
we're catching the nuances
of like maybe this we thought were slow
parts because there's no action or
whatever it's like
now i'm like taking it in with the
storytelling i'm like
this film is like a korean film
masterpiece
yeah like it's it's great it's the most
like i could say um
came out in 2001 yeah right so i was
in 11th grade yeah 10th grade so like uh
obviously your parents went to the vhs
store to rent it right and watch it
like what were their like impressions of
that well my parents i don't know if my
i think my i didn't see it with my
parents i saw it with a bunch of my
friends right so they didn't want me to
watch
these type of films you know it was
somebody getting stabbed in the stomach
32 times
that's another thing like the stabbing
the [ __ ]
stabbing in this movie there's no guns
guys there's no guns
because guns are illegal in korea yeah a
lot of stabbing
and just get ready to stomach that kind
of stuff yeah so so in general
if you guys don't know like ed said guns
are illegal in korea so when you see a
lot of gang violence just like bats
pipes two by fours and specifically this
uh sashimi knife yeah that you see
a lot yeah it's like why is everybody a
sushi
[Laughter]
no guns bro but it's essentially like a
mini katana yeah
right but my dad would rent that [ __ ]
over and over again and watch it over
and over again right
so like specifically one story so like
uh
when i first smoked weed was i was in
like 50 like
i was 15 years old i was like 10th grade
and
they opened up the weed and then to like
smoke it i was like
my first time smelling weed right i'm
like actually i've smelled this before
right where have i smelled this it's
from my
dad just chilling on the couch maxed out
watching chingu
and it's like it smells like pine cones
in here
you know what's so funny i watch that
[ __ ] so much when i
like i was uh relatively
ignorant to a lot of things right
because a lot of the stuff that i was
introduced to in terms of like drugs
like
you know crack cocaine-based all this
other stuff right was
a pretty normal part of life in my in
the neighborhood that my parents
was in right so this is not stuff that i
really sat there and second guessed or
knew what was going on right because my
parents were shielding me from it even
though i was there the whole time
i remember when i was in high school
right and people were smoking weed
and i was i smelt it i was like it
smells like my parents store here
i was like why did you smell like my
pears you know
i know what's going on and they're like
yo that's like
what's going on here they're like it's
like this weed i'm like that's weed
i've been smelling this [ __ ] my whole
life so i associated the smell
of that with my parents store whoa cause
everybody would smoke weed
you know right in front of the store all
the time but i assume that was
cigarettes you're so [ __ ] funny dude
yeah and you so yeah my dad watched this
movie all the time
and the way my mom would explain it too
because she'd pick it up and watch it
but there's a certain point to where she
she hates it but that
the beginning parts of this movie like
my parents both they just love it
when you watch it it's such a throwback
to the life and times right that
just that opening scene of uh this
foggy ass truck going to the streets and
the kids like playing in the
all that smoke kind of thing yeah i'm
watching and i'm confused
about like what's that smoke or whatever
and i asked my mom she's like yeah we
used to chase the truck
like but it's all dirty now i know it's
unhealthy you shouldn't do that
but she's like yeah the kids we go
around like and my mom would explain
like these simpler times that she lived
in
back like 60s 70s korea and so she had a
nostalgia for
two actually and yeah my dad as well
just
loved that opening scene where you see
simple life they're like
watching the babies go through and [ __ ]
yeah yeah just straight up about it yeah
this podcast is brought to you by
skillshare my friends no matter what
2021 brings you
you can spend it by creating something
meaningful with skillshare's online
classes because
time is what we make of it with
skillshare you can find inspiration in
the moment and learn how to express your
creativity
my friends if you want to talk about
classes i've been taking
well let's start with this we should
talk about plants at home to uplift your
spirit and your
space because my friends my place be
drab as hell
and i need a little foliage to lift up
my
spirits now if you're a type of person
out there that doesn't like learning
on somebody else's schedule skillshare
is that for you
there are so many classes and courses
that you can take that will help you
take your hobby to the next level your
business to the next level
any of these courses that you can think
of that will help you get to that next
part of your life your hobby whatever
your interest skillshare has it and i
love love love how it's all organized
and ready to go by credible people
teaching you the right things explore
your creativity at skillshare.com
brain and get a free trial of premium
membership that's skillshare.com
brain skillshare.com brain explore your
creativity at skillshare.com
brain like nostalgically for my parents
like
yeah they loved it so i always it was on
a lot actually my home yeah
it's interesting because when you watch
this film you get to see
it does remind me of the godfather a lot
oh not so much good fellas
because you're watching somebody from
when they're a kid all the way through
their adulthood and then after
yeah and so like in the beginning of the
film you see like this motley group of
friends
which is like your neighborhood friends
right so in korea uh
i'm pretty sure it's like this in japan
too but usually the people that you're
in school with in class with those are
your friends for the rest of your life
for life from elementary school all the
way till until grade school and above
you're usually until you go to college
or university or whatever those are the
same people that you grow up for life so
they have these huge bonds even my dad
now he still has
the same friends in korea from when he
was a little kid till this day
bro my husband is 80. and she went to
korea a few years ago and she called me
the cacao and she said yeah i'm with
my elementary school friends what
yeah like that's special like yeah maybe
that's the government system putting the
public
whatever out there but man that's
something special that yeah
we don't really will never know i guess
exactly so when you see
like uh if any korean kids are out there
and you see a picture
of your dad with these people in the
group when they were in high school
those are the friends that he had since
he was a little kid since he was in
preschool
um so they all kind of go through the
schooling system together in the same
class and they grow up together in that
same neighborhood yeah
so it's so the kind of movie starts off
with that type of weird friendship and
every person in that group has a very
unique
personality yeah there's the there's the
goofy guy i forgot his name
so i actually wrote notes okay because
last time we did mulan just off the top
of the dome yeah yeah
i'm pretty impressed with how long we
talked about that [ __ ] because we were
so upset with that
of course it burned in my memory for the
rest of my life because we love this
movie i want to do it right yeah so i
actually wrote some notes of like the
plot and whatever so
the film follows the lives of four uh
childhood friends
tunsuk the leader of the group and his
father is the
powerful mob boss tongsu whose father
is an undertaker right and he's the
second captain right yeah uh class clown
chung ho
that's an 80d kid right and sangtek
who is exemplary student just straight a
he's kind of a square
but they're all been friends since like
childhood
right do you ever like see yourself in
some of these kids though when you watch
it off the bat oh 100
right yeah especially like someone for
me is tongsu
that chip on the shoulder kind of guy
yeah right that'll that'll move on
so the first thing is like uh
1974 right and he's like my aunt just
got a new vhs player it's like what is
that
a video recorder what is that so i think
the best part of it like
is that it's opening up and like um
showing us the time and place through
technology something we understand
because we're watching a movie yeah
right so it's like yeah i'll show you at
home what it is and what do they put on
porn baby which is so
reminiscent of a bunch of boys boys yep
yo i can't tell you how many
nudie mags i found in the forest like
literally flint in the woods hanging out
and there's a [ __ ] nudie mag dude in
washington
in the forest there's a nudie mac dude
there's this one kid in my high school
uh and even before high school but let
me i just i'll just say this one so
there's one kid in my high school this
dude was this black dude his name was
shane
so i was a very interesting guy he used
to he used to uh this is during the time
that we would like burn cds
and this new shade was so unique because
usually black people didn't burn cds
that was an asian person thing
at our school but then you know he had a
lot of asian friends i was one of his
asian friends so he was doing like the
asian people [ __ ] which was burning cds
and trying to sell them and [ __ ] like
that
did he drive an integra
he this whole had uh some [ __ ] uh
what do you call those those fake
spinnies
oh yeah in his [ __ ] car it was like a
whole jedi yeah
and so he uh i remember this
would burn uh [ __ ] uh hentai onto
these little
into these vcd files on these cds
and he would sell it to some of the
black kids that [ __ ] with anime but
didn't want to openly say they liked
anime yeah
but they were he was i was like oh you
you're selling them like
anime goes not hentai they're [ __ ]
watching cartoons [ __ ] each other like
what the [ __ ] is going on capitalist
that's what these kids do too
right it shows their innocence because
they don't know
what uh [ __ ] is yeah right and it's
like
they call it no it's called the
menstruation yeah they're having this
conversation about like women parts and
stuff
so it's showing the inner sense like
they're
they're like you know problem kids
because they're watching porns but
they're still so enough they have no
idea what they're seeing kind of thing
but in turn still what they do with it
is that they
they capitalize on it like your friend
and they start selling the porn
and then chun seok the captain starts
acting like the enforcer with this
taekwondo shirt on
so all this like lifestyle [ __ ] is like
happening like
in their dna they're just like doing
this [ __ ] as kids the hierarchy of their
group is already started
it's already established it's
establishing yeah
so um they go to a hobby store
and tongsu finds a fake knife
and that's what we were talking about
just like
um what do you call it like a precursor
or like a
it's it's it's foreshadowing
foreshadowing yeah
although it's just like get ready for a
lot of knives
man just get ready and then um
pretty much they it kind of goes forward
to high school and they all fall in love
with that lead singer
and um son tech
holds up like a party and it's not
santek uh
uh tunsuk yeah yeah the leader he holds
a party at his place where he gets the
band to come in
right and when he shows up though
tshantek the square
he's there because he wants to meet the
girls and then chun sook
starts clowning him and busting his
balls for being a square
yeah and he gets all pissed off snaps
and like
tries to act like a tough guy and shuts
off the music and it's just
awkward like he wasn't made for that
[ __ ] right
and they talk outside and then tune lets
his feelings be known
like dude like you're my friend why are
you coming here
you know at my house like by the way so
his dad's a mobster he has a really nice
big house
yeah and sangtek never comes over
but he only comes over when there's
girls and so he was upset about that and
he's explaining that and so
as a peace offering he he offers the
girl right
the lead singer to have a one-on-one
and what happens tongsu tongsu gets
jealous
so he confronts him in the bathroom now
what's that say about the korean culture
just like has his pants down the dick
out just taking a piss like what the
[ __ ] man
it was this is also too like
it's relationship building because
you'll see the relationship between
sangtek and um the leader
you'll see their friendship specifically
throughout this whole film and this is
like
uh a little gem that they're showing to
you and how much their friendship
evolves
he actually holds their friendship to a
very very high standard
so mind you as we just mentioned chunk
is the
the boss he's like the chang he is the
[ __ ]
scary as [ __ ] everybody fears him to
death beats the [ __ ] out of everybody
but he has this really huge soft spot
soft spot for this specific friend
and i think what he likes about him is
the fact that even though he's so
different from him he still he he speaks
to him honestly
yeah always at all times doesn't care
that he's the the high school chiang or
whatever
so he could always count on him to
always be honest and be truthful with
him
and i think that kind of shows like a
little bit of how their friendship
evolves throughout the whole film
and the film starts establishing like um
santek's household
they have a very solid family like
they're eating dinner together watching
tv and they have plans to buy a house
right and but then the other guys
it shows their life in the classroom
where uh the the adhd kid
gets he has a little comedic scene he's
trying to hide and he gets
beat right yeah for me it shows how
koreans don't believe in adhd
yeah and they will beat the [ __ ] out of
you for like what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you
yeah so just to give a little background
um i'm it's not like this now from what
i heard from other people
it's not as violent as before but back
in the day when my parents told me that
he was in grade school
these these teachers would beat the [ __ ]
out of these kids
for having a bad grade yeah for having a
bad grade not paying attention in class
goofing off when i say beat the [ __ ] out
of you i'm talking about what's this
movie
like yeah like you think it's an
exaggeration in the film
from what my dad told me goes no that's
what it would be
they would sock them in the face punch
them in the stomach get a stick beat the
[ __ ] out of them in class
so one of the very like uh one of the
most important scenes is
uh tunsauk and tongsu are in trouble
because they had bad grades
and so the teachers lining up all the
bad grade students and making an example
of all of them and he's asking them
what does your father do for a living
this is such a good scene right yeah
and he asked them what they do oh okay
so your dad does that and
just beats them and you're getting bad
grades when you work so hard
tongsu goes up and he says my father's
an undertaker
right and piece of [ __ ] i'm okay so your
dad works hard
and he gives him the stink eye yeah
getting the stink eye back so
the teacher hits him even more right
well one last time
and then he walks away like a hard ass
chun-su comes up
grabs him by the cheek and says what's
your father do and then he goes and then
he says
like the gangster right yeah gangster
like mobster monster
and then he beats the ever living out of
him yeah he's like you think that's
special or some [ __ ]
and he beating him and he fights back
and he goes you think that's a good
thing
yeah right who said is a good that i
didn't say is a good thing right
and that shows that his self-awareness
of the environment he grew in like he
knows
like this is my life situation yeah i
never said it like i was proud of it
yeah it's not good or whatever
and that shows tongs to his behavior
though with his dad who loves him
why are you like this because he wants
to be like junso
yeah you know and meanwhile chung wants
to be like sangtek
exactly and so look this is a
quite [ __ ] storytelling movie like
this is so good like as it goes on
um so as
uh they they get into a fight at like a
skating rink right yeah
um what's his name is
trying to like he's [ __ ] looking
yeah and then gets in trouble with some
guys right from a rival school
and they just punk the [ __ ] out of him
because he's actually pretty square
right and they [ __ ] put a knife to
his neck
right it was like a barber blade yeah
yeah and
yeah barbara blade and then the the two
badasses
you know tunsuke and dongsu come and
save the day and they just school those
guys
and then they line them up make them
count up
and then they let me just beat the [ __ ]
out of them
the funniest line about that too was
like when when they come in
and so sunk takes getting his ass but
not aspy but they put the the barber
blade
um the razor blade next to his throat or
whatever right
and then uh
[Music]
comes in and just [ __ ] shaky kicks
but you could tell how menacing they are
in terms of their reputation
specifically as a kang pe or as a group
when he looks at him he goes
he goes let me see that knife let me see
it
what are you waiting
what are you doing with this cute little
thing which kind of just shows how
domineering and scary
because they've been at this since they
were children yeah right and all the
other people their age they established
them so that's the weird thing about
korea is how
people establish themselves and their
reputations in high school
you know that's why it's like that ego
thing gets built there
but if you watch closely chunsok
actually doesn't do anything
yeah he sits in the back and tongsu is
doing all the work
and when they put him in the in that
hallway and they're just smoking
cigarettes while
they let tonk beat the [ __ ] out of them
the camera pants
shin sun's not even watching yeah down
the stairs he wants no
part of that stuff so it says something
about his character with what's going on
here which will
later show um and then like
after that i think uh chun suk tells
like don't just start a fight you have
to finish it or that guy's gonna come
back for you right which he does which
he does
yeah i gotta go back to that just the
action of humiliating
humiliating people that's the kind of
[ __ ] that
i did but that kid right yeah yeah yeah
i never finished that story dude
actually there's actually an ending so
last time i was here i shared a story
about how i
my friends and i made this guy kiss
my sister's foot right and i never
actually finished it but
the story but just like what happened in
this movie because
you know my friend stepped in for me and
said either ed's gonna beat you up
or you gotta kiss his feet like and all
20 kids
saw and over the years they came back
right
like i think a couple years after iraq
i came back here um and i was filming
this b-boy event
right yeah and um this b-boy event in
seattle and then we're all setting up
we're there early and the dj is going
setting up
and it's that kid it's him
he's like this big boy in seattle and
he's a dj
this podcast is brought to you by purple
my friends is the mattress you're
sleeping on making you very sad
and uncomfortable well that's because
you don't have a purple
mattress i have never slept as well as i
do right now and in fact
when you don't sleep well don't you know
that it messes up your cognitive ability
you can't think straight that's why
you're mumbling all the time that's why
when you're trying to lie to your wives
and your husbands you're like
hey i don't know it's because you don't
have a purple mattress and you haven't
slept well so you can't
lie better i have been lying so well
ever since i've had my purple mattress
i'm kidding by the way but seriously
purple mattress has
the best technology when it comes to
their mattress we're talking about
proprietary
technology yes the comfort and the
instant
body adaptation that it does to your
body when you sleep
to match your sleeping style is not like
any other mattress out there
no hassle shipping and returns first
free trial sleep now
and paid later because purple has
financing available as low as 0
apr for qualified customers who you can
get to sleep in
amazing as soon as possible my genius
brain listeners experience the purple
grid and you'll sleep like never before
go to purple.com gb10 and use promo code
gb10 for a limited time you'll get 10
off any order of 200 or more that's
purple.com
gb10 promo code gb10 for 10
off any order of 200 or more terms apply
i'm like oh [ __ ] right it's like what's
your b-boy name my me my name is dj
[Laughter]
kisses
but man i [ __ ]
i [ __ ] finished it man like uh i went
up to him
as he was setting up and he saw me he
was like oh [ __ ] he froze
yeah i was like hey man and i stuck my
hand out
i was like i'm really sorry yeah i'm
really sorry for what happened
two years ago and he took my hand and
we're both tearing up bro
and i was like look man i shouldn't have
done that to your cat and he was like no
i was stupid i was a dumb kid or
whatever
and we hugged it out did the event so
there's a happy ending to that guys
there's a happy
ending to that wasn't a total [ __ ]
yeah also my sister
even she told me later after she heard
the podcast she was like
hey did you know i actually called him
later and apologized for that too
oh wow that's nuts i'm [ __ ] proud of
you i love you
that's so funny at the b-boy jam he just
starts playing r b music only
he's like can you not play the vitamin c
graduation song as we're trying to b-boy
as we're trying to dance here please i
just like the thing about when i was
watching that scene again i was like
[ __ ] like my parents didn't teach me
that i didn't we didn't see chingu and
do that yeah
like i was like damn that's just in the
korean dna to
[ __ ] do something to a [ __ ]
like subjugate somebody
yeah that's the han man a lot of korean
punishment's like that too though
you know oh yeah like tegari pago like
take your hands behind your head
so you take out apogo you basically put
your hand behind your back
you forget on your yeah it's just it
sucks dude like and you just gotta hit
your face to a fist
there's other stuff too where you have
to take your hands behind your back
your feet and then you balance your
forehead and your oh my god off the
ground i [ __ ] hated that [ __ ] dude
that [ __ ] sucks so bad i think part of
my like big shoulders is because
my dad made me raise my eyes yeah
but yeah like all those even though it's
like terrible scenes for sure that's
like ah that's us
oh that's good that's us so
what happens is like because chun suk
was like finish your fights it gave him
a piece of
advice sangtek offers him a piece of
advice
go back and apologize you know after
that that teacher beat him and they
walked out of class
go back and come back to school he's
like all right
and they go and do it right and to
celebrate
there's this big montage where they race
and it's just like they run to the
movies
just they're still kids right even
though they're hard asses
and then what happens the rival school
kids see him
see him at the theater and a [ __ ]
riot breaks out
just beats the [ __ ] out of the bathroom
they beat the [ __ ] out of him and
uh tunsuk and tongsu have to come save
his ass
and it's like four versus 200 or some
[ __ ]
wild event or whatever ultimately
big big trouble the police come and you
know you just hear the police whistles
and
face the black yeah sangtek
in this panic of trouble this is
something he's never
been in before steals his parents money
that they were saving to buy a house
and runs away to his gangster friend
chun seok right
yeah to be like let's run away to seoul
right and what does chunsok do though
jesus says no he goes i'm gonna live my
life
you do what you have to do and they go
their separate ways
like the the thing what
what happens is like like we talked
about before is chunks of where
right he was like man did you think that
i was being like yeah let's go
yeah he's like no no dude
like you have good parents you know
go back home to your parents and face
your punishment because he said when he
was a kid
his mom was sick and nobody
was taking care of him or whatever so he
ran away from home and he was missing
for days
right yeah until he cut anywhere and he
came back home
and all his uncles and his dad nobody
gave a [ __ ]
yeah nobody punished him yeah right and
it's like he was saying he's like man we
split up in middle school and got back
together in high school
you know yeah if i went to middle school
with you i would have been a good
student like you
yeah he's like ha if those time tunes
[ __ ] beat the [ __ ] out of me and
taught me my lesson i would have [ __ ]
got my [ __ ] together
yeah and he's just like this this is my
life
he's like don't join me right and he
sends him on his way it's like
which is like you know it goes back to
them planting the seeds of their
relationship and their friendship of how
he looks at his life and he's actually
kind of envious of it you know he's like
i really wish i had what you had
like don't look at me and look up to me
because i actually look up to you
you know even though he's the leader and
the boss yeah but he's looking at him
and saying like i really wish
i had what you had and he almost for his
sake he wants to protect his innocence
right you know he doesn't want to be the
person that tarnishes his life
right you know because like all
throughout the movie when you
uh when it cuts through um like you
start seeing like his dad
doesn't [ __ ] give a [ __ ] about him it
has to not
give a [ __ ] about his kid like as you
see it and so he
he has like a lot of resentment right
and
so sangtek goes home and you could hear
his dad scream
yeah but they said my mom just opened
silently opened the door
you know and who knows what happened if
you got the [ __ ] beat out of him he's
like he went back home
he faced this punishment he went back to
his family
and he they go off to college right and
they go to
visit uh chun suk you know it's like
some years have passed
[ __ ] is a meth he's a [ __ ]
meth crackhead yeah he's out of it dude
this is why like
koreans have some of the best acting his
face when he's like
you know like i'll tear your [ __ ] apart
yeah this dude
when they go see him together they're a
little older they're obviously a lot
more mature
and then he has that classic asian fur
blanket on him you know
it's funny because the blanket that he
has on him is like i have that exact
same blanket everyone has like
the exact same one right he's shivering
he's actually he's actually on
uh uh he's coming down from a high yeah
right so he's going through withdrawals
and [ __ ] yeah and when they open the
door they actually see
the girl that he was trying to set up
something with
right right and so it's a little
shocking he ends up marrying the girl
like and
it goes back to show that like uh
chun-sook back in they had
all sorts of confidence and
self-awareness he's like this girl's
already mine go ahead and have him
yeah time with her or some [ __ ] right
but
there's a real tragedy to her character
too isn't it
like what she could have been is
supposed to be because of her talent and
her popularity
like because for korean girls like maybe
you're on top because like of all
that beauty or talent or whatever a dude
at the top in a korean high school is a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
and it's like the reality of what you
see like she's super pretty he's very
beautiful
korean prom king with korean palm queen
is not a walk in the pool yeah right and
it's crazy because like he the way he's
talking about her
it's like he's saying like i kept it
around because the [ __ ] was good yeah
so you know why wouldn't i just
verbally abusing her and saying just
like crazy [ __ ] curse words
where it's just like we understand
because like our parents are probably
said some
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] like that too but he
is hounding her with that
yeah he's like telling her it's like so
there's like a part two where
you know she's coming in and she's doing
like the housewives stuff bringing in
drinks and snacks or whatever
and then um you know she smiles at
whatever tongue tech and and then he
looks at her
and you could tell him he's like a
little jealous right and that's when he
starts
flipping out saying it's like oh you
want to [ __ ] my friends because they're
college kids
like they're they're college educated he
goes i'll [ __ ] rip your [ __ ] and
have fun
he's like saying some terrible [ __ ]
terrible thing you know but and it goes
to show
and this is where you get to see that
relationship between santek
and him because he comes in and even
though this pulls like a
cracked out meth head mob boss he looks
and goes hey cut that [ __ ] out
yeah like you're doing too much and he
goes i'm sorry right because
tongsu tried that [ __ ] on him yeah put
his hand on him
he's like what am i to you mm-hmm you
know because he was like why didn't you
give me this girl
right he's questioning what a friend
means to tunsak
tongsu at this time you know and he's
he's like what am i your sidekick yeah
right if he's your friend what am i
but chunsuk never answers him and that's
one of his mistakes he looks
back at him with the [ __ ] death star
and says
yeah right and so in turn like which is
that thing where you when you're looking
up to someone
and they're telling it through this
story where something can be like yeah
you're right he's just like talking down
to him he's like oh oh oh
yeah i'm sorry yeah yeah which is wild
to see but like you're seeing the
respect that he has for a guy which
later on also plays through
um let's see
tongsu at that point though
all that mayhem and chaos happened right
and
what's the next thing that he's doing
because he's expelled from school he's
cleaning a [ __ ] dead body with his
dad
yeah yeah yeah yeah right and his
demeanor is just like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] right instead it's like
all right and
when i saw that scene i was like this
guy's not alarmed by
dead bodies he doesn't want to clean
dead bodies he want to make
dead bodies yeah you know because he
wants to be like chunzo so bad and he's
just like looking at his future
cleaning dead bodies for people and he
leaves [ __ ] this [ __ ] but what's he do
after that
he causes this big scene at the school
with
the bat and breaks all the windows in
the trophies and all that [ __ ]
to make a scene for himself something
children's up would never do he wasn't
even there for that
yeah right and he's gonna go out there
he's gonna be
he chooses to be a gangster and make a
name for himself to me when i watch that
thing that was his saying like
i will never be like my dad and he was
making sure that he has no way to turn
back
yeah so he goes ahead makes sure that he
will never be allowed back in school
so there's no turning back at this point
right no turning back so but look at
chun suk situation as a drug addict
when tongue tech goes to take him out to
buy christmas card
right yeah the reason why like
the drug addict i could understand it's
like his mom dying his dad [ __ ] hates
him it won't buy him clothes for the
winner that's why
he's like shivering you know he calls
him a half human
and all that [ __ ] and
he's telling him like he has nothing
offer he's like but if you want someone
me to kill somebody i'll kill them
[ __ ] kill him i'll kill him i'll kill
him good
you know um and that's all he has
left that's like all he is you know
whereas tongsu just
wants to be that for some reason yeah
you know and during this time too
um what after the time lapse happens
they asked for tongs
tongs was actually in jail right in jail
so in order for him to come up in the
gang
he has to go to jail he has to go to
jail and
and she's just like i already been there
like three or four times yeah
you've seen some [ __ ] and like uh but it
cuts to
tongsu coming out of prison who's there
to see him
not like the korean tradition of when
you come out of prison
or white cake something white like
purity like you've been atoned you you
did your time
yeah his dad is there doing the right
thing and loving him showing up for him
his gank his conqueror friends aren't
there his friends well he has no
let's what i'm seeing is he obviously
doesn't appreciate his dad he gets kind
of embarrassed like
dad bringing him to and the fact that
he's also alone he actually doesn't have
friends yeah
mean meanwhile the other guys are
visiting chun seok you know
and when it cuts through um
basically uh
chun-sook in order to get clean he just
leaves his father's house right
and follows the second hand man in
charge instead
and he leaves um his
his current boss to follow this other
boss
his current boss is feeding him the
drugs right
and then there's that scene when he
faces him in the chinese restaurant
oh yeah so [ __ ] badass
he has he takes the the knife he
sterilizes it with
over this candle and he literally puts a
blade to his face and he starts cutting
he goes hey don't worry it's sterilized
and he starts cutting his face and he
just has to take it i'm like
holy [ __ ] you could have been like drink
this pee it's sterilized
exactly it's like oh what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
but he's giving him a speech of loyalty
he's like you [ __ ] i gave you
all the drugs you wanted and just how
you trust you treat me you're gonna
leave me
you know but that's the way he lets him
leave by that
[ __ ] knife in his head yeah you know
and and lets him
leave meanwhile cut to tongsu now
now back in society he's at the same
restaurant
and goes to that boss to get a job
now because chun suk left and he wants
to take his place
yeah you know following in his friend's
footsteps
and perfect time perfect opportunity and
the good money
that he sees with it so
the next scene being um his uh
chun-suk's father's funeral so
big funeral and all that he's wearing
the whole getup
hello cool with it all these shots are
so [ __ ] beautiful the lighting is
like this natural
it's so so great and
they're having a smoke outside right and
they're catching up with what the
friends are up to and he tells him
i'm going to work for your old boss
right and then like chin sucks
pissed because he's like yo this guy
sells drugs to kids and yeah
so like tunzo at this point
doesn't fall for this his old boss's
loyalty speech
this idea of loyalty of the hand that
feeds you is [ __ ]
the hands that feeds you is just toxic
or whatever he's like don't deal with
that man
but tungsu's situation you're like what
is he going to do
you know the last job is cleaning his
chuteok's father
yeah you know and so tunsuk
understanding
each other's situation and tungsten
situation
you know planet of the apes when they
put their hand down
that's what it reminded me of yeah it
was [ __ ] the blessing he got the
blessing
from his captain to be his own man
you know then it cuts right like well
i mean he walks out into the alleyway
it's just this beautiful shot he's like
hey thank your dad for
you know doing my father's body now yeah
he's like i'll call him tonight
and it just stays on that shot and he
just walks into the darkness and it's
just like
what the [ __ ] when i was a kid like this
such a beautiful [ __ ] movie
yeah yeah there's so much story to it
guys you guys you gotta
you gotta watch it man and then where's
it cuts to
the highway the highway the time skip
yeah the time skid so it's like 1990 91.
uh there's a cab going and then
we're seeing a pov of the limo that chin
sucks in
and then this whole crew they pull over
this taxi
and they see you know twist of fate it's
and then they [ __ ] hit the window and
all that [ __ ] this will literally
almost curb the taxi off of the [ __ ]
highway just to stop him like a [ __ ]
kangpe would
you know right just to see his friend
and
the next scene is just like so beautiful
like
these gunpez these football it's like
you wonder why there's no korean like
rugby or football players they're all
gunk
yeah they're all the largest men are a
bunch of bodyguards so
at this point just to put things in
perspective chunk has now cleaned
himself up
yeah right so he has actually made a big
name for himself within the mob
gong peg group right so he's very well
respected now he's off of drugs he's not
doing any of that [ __ ] and now he's
running [ __ ]
right as one there's there's still the
older bosses but he's
like a step below that so he's very well
revered
within the group so the the movie is so
brilliant when it starts showing the
journey between
um tongsu and choonsak here because
while they're drinking and hamming it up
over some kalbi
um chunks talking about the
[ __ ] reformations he's making within
the game within
the [ __ ] like organization and how
he's taking care of people
and his and whatever and he's doing like
innovations within the insides and
trade deals but tong tech
is all drunk and [ __ ] he doesn't even
respect
chun suk at all and he's like gosh
you're still a [ __ ] gangster dude
you're a gangster because he was kind of
making comparisons of like see like you
went to college and like
i'm smart too i can do all this stuff
he's like the [ __ ] are you talking about
at the end of the day you're still a
[ __ ] gangster yeah and then the two
kangas in the back gave him the stinker
yeah and then the best thing is
he basically looks at the two guys he
goes basically and cringy's telling like
hey get your ass over here
right he goes you lost your [ __ ] mind
you know it's like who the [ __ ] are you
looking at like that
it's like saying that's his friend yeah
that's my friend yeah
dare you it's like you don't deserve to
eat yeah
go he said go sit in the trunk and hold
your balls and think about what you said
you repent
so the crazy thing about this scene it
goes
back to how much he respects his the
friendship that he has between him and
tongue tank
right so and they don't those two they
just see oh somebody's talking [ __ ] to
our boss so we gotta do something
but they didn't realize they overstepped
their boundaries like you don't ever
speak to my friend that way like what's
even doesn't realize the power he has
being sucks friends
yeah and he's like oh we're just friends
yeah
yeah and it's a thing though like when
you see this [ __ ] like
chunzo takes it on the chin every time
sangtek tells him what's up
yeah you know and he he just
sits there and takes it and he [ __ ]
with anyone who has anything else to say
about it and that's
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] dope it's like
loyalty and friendship and the cool
thing about that there's a very popular
a phrase that they say in that
and what it translates to is uh it's
like he basically says hey i'm sorry i
was out of line and he's like
why do friends do apologize to each
other like this doesn't have to be said
it's the unconditional love that they
understand yeah and
it's like when we talk about han and the
hate and the resentment
and the [ __ ] anger the other side
the intense passionate friendship and
love
is there too like friends don't have to
apologize with each other i mean like
i'm sorry if you see
like koreans hanging out with each other
all the time but there's like a special
bond you're like i gotta understand that
you know um and the beauty of this
movie like translating that on the
screen and showing like
it like really come to work yeah it's so
great between
opposite worlds right and he takes his
words and it's just like you know
uh they cut to the scene like i've seen
this [ __ ] remember my
dad's friends would try to like
overbought them like carry them on their
back they're all drunk and [ __ ]
oh that scene is the best so literally
he's drunk and he's giving him a
piggyback ride he's like i've been
waiting to do this for you
yeah and then but it's still the most
gangster way
the the the lackeys are still in the
trunk of the [ __ ] limo
holding their balls as his personal
driver is still driving next to him in
an empty alleyway or an empty road they
hit a speed bump in the trunk
and like i wish like people understand
the subtlety of korean humor and
filmmaking like they didn't say [ __ ]
they showed it
yeah it's like that's filmmaking like
korean filmmaking is top notch we love
it guys so we love it it's the best
thing too because
even then like hung pick in his
ultimate wisdom and nice kindness he
goes hey that's enough let them out of
the trunk
and he goes oh okay he looks at he's too
laggy he goes
are you guys tired and hungry you guys
want to come out he's like he's like
i don't know yeah he goes see they're
fine
they just stay in the truck this bounces
at the top of the truck is smacking
their head
oh my gosh dude and i can i can recall
like the time
my dad i got in trouble once
where my dad made me stand outside with
no pants and a t-shirt
and i had to stand out there holding my
balls yo what the [ __ ] is with parents
korean parents stripping the kids butt
naked and kicking him out yeah let me
tell you this funny story so
my mom told me um not too long ago and
she was kind of making comparisons of
how
me and my brother were as kids and so my
mom said like my brother was a very very
stubborn child
yeah like if if he was set on doing
something he was going to do it no
matter what the kid had balls and i was
like what do you mean
she goes well when we were in korea and
you were really really small at the time
and this is when your brother was about
four years old so he was in preschool
so i was washing dishes and i was
telling your brother to go
clean up his toys and he ignores me
and he just continues to play with his
toys and my mom goes
you know like i'm a count of three if
you don't clean up your toys you're
gonna get your ass whip right
looks at my mom with like this look goes
i don't care
it starts doing whatever and she goes
hey and then my mom
you know my mom's a thug she don't give
a [ __ ] she does she goes i'm gonna beat
your ass she goes
do you wanna live outside this is my
house he goes fine i'll go live outside
this is a four-year-old kid right so
he'll he he goes fine i'm gonna go live
outside
so in the cutest [ __ ] ever he gets his
little preschool backpack starts
stuffing it with his toys right cause
he's gonna leave and go live outside
this isn't the dead of winter in korea
it's cold as [ __ ] so my mom
looks at him and she goes oh you think
this is your stuff that's my stuff
she rips the backpack off of him strips
him butt
naked i'm talking about balls out baby
dick out everything right
[Laughter]
[ __ ] kicks him out leaves him in
front of the door of the house
locks the door right and my mom said
like your brother is so stubborn
he didn't cry for the first like 15
minutes and he just stood up it was dead
silent and she goes what's going on and
she kind of looks out the window
and he's out there not crying just like
stubborn still upset
and for 15 [ __ ] minutes butt naked
outside until he goes
he's like i [ __ ] up i'm so sorry yeah
that's like that's the thing that was
like the korean punishment it's like
i actually this is my stuff like you're
a guest in my house
know your [ __ ] role you know know
your [ __ ] position
i gotta tell you you know whenever i got
a beating like my dad would
challenge me in a way like how many
lashings do you think you deserve this
time right
and i'd have to come up with a number
and he determined if it was too low and
he'd say wise too low
and [ __ ] it's like so i'd have to figure
out exactly
what my punishment was worth worst thing
my dad used that thing where he would
bring out his fist and tell me to punch
him
yeah it's like you have any idea what
kind of sadistic [ __ ]
you have to be to tell your kid to punch
their own face into your face
it's like i didn't beat my kid he beat
himself up like it ran into my face
domestic abuse oh this is american dream
they made korean korean punishment fit
inside of america
oh my god by making us punch ourselves
into their fists dude
so [ __ ] funny oh man and anyway uh
back to the movie
so we're seeing tungsok he's a the
[ __ ] man
he's the [ __ ] man right and
though who is he what's he up to right
first scene you just see this girl
kind of clicking some heroine and you
see some
booty and some muff diving it's like raw
and then they're passed out on the bed
um and
you see a flash right and it's tongsu
and his crew they're extorting this
they're blackmailing him
to extort him for a contract a
construction contract
yeah which he gets that drug dealing
boss to win the lottery
to do so he's doing shady [ __ ] but he's
doing it out loud
he's letting it be known he's like so
that his name gets out there
and meanwhile tunsil is doing it the
other way
where he's like really bringing
reformation within
so when you see them at the karaoke
and they're singing and he's singing my
way by uh i did it my way by uh
thanks sinatra yeah like man beautiful
filmmaking from a korean perspective of
a gangster like doing a frank sinatra
song yeah there's a little hint in there
right
and he truly does do it his weight in
the entire time
meanwhile tongs is doing it chun suk's
way yeah from what he thinks he knows
yeah right like this is what a kang
pants yeah this is what a kang pe is and
he's looking up
and up to chunsuk still behind the
scenes
and when you see like uh
let's see let me bring it back to my
notes
you know there was this i think there
was a scene before that was very
poignant right because
he's that that karaoke thing was them
sending him off somewhere right oh
santa's going back to america
exactly he's going back to america but
he goes see he's getting like a suit
tailored
exactly and there was one part they sent
chills through my spine
because it showed that the tumultuous
relationship that they have
where tongs was still trying to be
either
an equal to him or better better right
still trying to show something but he
does something very very small
that she speaks volumes so he's like hey
our friends are going to leave he's like
okay he's like playing at nonchalant he
goes
he's like he doesn't acting like he
doesn't even remember who sanjak is
right this [ __ ]
yeah it's like oh yeah i remember him
blah blah blah he goes
all right we'll come either way and he
puts his hand on his shoulder pop
right and that you could tell it pissed
him off
yeah like even till now i'm still your
[ __ ] sidekick after i've done
all this [ __ ] because tomsu's bodyguards
have taken
over that boutique right yeah they're
[ __ ] running amok
but this other boss chun suk walks in
and
and he puts his hand on tongsu and walks
away with it yeah and you can see
tongsu's face like he can't do [ __ ]
still
yeah he still can't do [ __ ] even though
they're [ __ ] equals and gang
yeah like that's [ __ ] baller of
chunzo yeah you know
and tongsu still feels that [ __ ] i'm
still like
underneath this guy right and like i
it's weird because of
the way like tongs like he the way he's
interpreting it is different from the
intense
intention of tune suck chun suk is not
just doing that as we're friends
yeah i'll see you around yo bro our bros
are in town and not just he's acting
like
he's the [ __ ] big shot because he
kind of is he built his way there he
made it
right but but he goes to his dad
goes to his dad to give him the money
he's made what's his dad do though
because you think i want your filthy
[ __ ] money you know
yeah this blood money the people like
all this [ __ ] it's like
when did i ask you to be a gangster when
i asked you to make money and
all these things i never had yeah like
dude vice versa us and our dads yeah
yeah exactly yeah because of that chip
on the shoulder tongsu has like to be
more than a [ __ ] undertaker yeah like
the thing is like
um one of the most important parts in
the scene comes
when tongsu puts into plan to get
chun suk's boss in jail yeah sucks boss
gets busted
right and what's tong so doing he's out
um
at the dock and he's smoking a cigarette
and one of
his lackeys pulls up to him like the job
is done
and tongsu asks him that question that
he has all his friends from their kids
who would win in a race right an olympic
swimmer or a sea turtle
right and that guy's like huh and
what that's that whole like debate right
it happens in the beginning of the movie
right where they debate about this and
then this is the second time
it comes up what do you think about what
the [ __ ] that
like sea turtle and the olympic swimmer
race
like was talking about it's the torch
and the hair thing
the length of the race versus you know i
i looked at it like they were arguing
that a sea turtle
is a natural in the water
that's chunzo he's born and bred
gangster
this is what it is this is what it is
and this is his lane
right for tongsu he has to adapt to the
water and learn to swim he has to learn
how to be a gangster
yeah right and when he asks his friend
that he realizes that he's not
a turtle he's not the sea turtle
right even though when he was a kid he's
like he knows a sea turtle would win
they're the natural in the water
yeah but in the unnatural he is the
olympic swimmer as
hard as he tries and gets up to the top
he's
whoever wins the race sea turtles are
natural in this game
yeah you know as hard as tongsu is
working
he still feels like [ __ ] chin sucks
sidekick yeah and [ __ ]
so tongsu takes down chun seok's boss
yeah and um
but what happens is chun suk's cousin
right who's in chun suk's ba uh gang
without chun suk's knowledge takes it
upon himself to go
and then one of the most badass scenes
ever you want to explain that
so basically um the cousin
actually asked basically saying like oh
we gotta take this dude out
and he was like kind of gave his cousin
the dirty look saying like
that's my friend yeah you know he he he
buried my father
yeah don't touch him right he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about what he says
and they stalk him they find out where
he lives waits for him to fall asleep
and he's with
his cousin and his other lackey they go
in to murder him
knows what's up like literally
shecky kicks him through one of the
doors beats the [ __ ] at them with either
a piper it was a bat or a pipe
yeah it was right and then he does this
gangster ass
thing where he takes his [ __ ] ankle
snaps it
so [ __ ] badass dude takes that
look he's an undertaker's kid he knows
anatomy bro
yup he knows anatomy and takes the knife
they don't show it
it's like when i was a kid i thought
he'd probably like cut his achilles heel
then i saw i saw the devil
i was like maybe he [ __ ] cut that
foot off yeah he broke the bone and cut
the foot off
ooh the pain that's when it starts yep
this is when the knifing starts get
ready
so the cool thing about this film too
when you see a lot of gangster films
that came out of this
it was just a lot of gratuitous violence
from beginning to end to the film
this film doesn't actually have that
there's a there's a lot of focus on
relationship building
yeah to get to the point so when you see
these skunk pit
situations happen the build-up is so
good you know because you're used to
seeing everything there's this weird
uneasy air between
everybody in the film but you're just
waiting for something to happen
and that hit that he's assuming that it
was chuseok's idea
yeah is that is the straw that broke the
camel's hump at that point he goes
oh it's on there now it's on and tongsu
now is out
for chinseok like we were never friends
right
right it just confirmed of what it
basically confirmed his deepest darkest
fears
right we were never equals none of you
ever considered me as friends
and so tongsu enacts revenge at the
docks
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] i don't know
how what if you call it a trigger
warning but it's like this is the movie
where i was like
when i watch a movie with guns you can
see
one knife one knife into someone's
stomach makes me
cringe so hard and while this scene is
playing out right
um beforehand they're actually
showing um the [ __ ]
the twin socks bodyguards appreciation
the love they have for chun suk
because when he's singing my way they're
[ __ ] crying
[Laughter]
they respect him they obey him they love
him and they
feel for him and then that dog workers
like they're eating ramyun together
what the [ __ ] bro why do you want to be
a gangster he's like i want to be like
yeah right and like that admiration
admiration that they have from
but tongsu comes in with this gang they
got the bats
they got the pipes and they got the
knives
yeah but in true cinematic storytelling
form
what's happening is um chunzo is
training
new trainees because he's on
he's definitely about like okay so we
missed a scene where
um you know tungsu is doing the loud
[ __ ] to make a name
chun suk is within his own group he's at
a meeting with
that apology guy yeah he's one of the
bosses yeah the bosses is like talking
[ __ ] to all of them and [ __ ] them
and like talking [ __ ] to tune song and
chunks like okay guys step outside
and when it's empty he starts laying it
on him
it's like you've never even been stabbed
you never went to jail
it's like this company that you run is
for
like what does he say for our hyung's in
jail
you know a retirement plan and for to
feed our men yeah like this guy
is literally reforming the gang from the
inside he's like doing it right
so you can see what chintzok is doing
like even though it's like
scary in gangster as hell he's doing
good
this scene is it's gangster and there's
also such a funny
moment to it because this guy is
literally like the
the king that doesn't do anything it
just gets fat fat off of its people
right and you
have chunk who is kind of like he's
i want to say it's it's rebellious in a
certain sense because he's actually
underhunted right but obviously the the
respect and what he's done in this group
is held to a very very high degree the
bosses gave him permission
at this moment when he tells everybody
to leave he looks at me as like you
[ __ ]
fat [ __ ] and the guy's like what did you
just say to me and he just brings out
that long korean sashimi knife
puts at the table he goes the bosses and
the person told me that i could kill you
yeah and they know what that means
they're like oh that means that
everybody wants me dead right and he
goes
you have basically fed your [ __ ] fat
self off of all of our hard work
you haven't gone to prison done all this
other stuff there's this awkward silence
and he looks at him he goes
[Laughter]
and truth like chun sucks [ __ ] like
[ __ ] like gangster gunpet death's
there to him yeah he said chingway i was
like ooh
because these actors are so [ __ ] good
he looks like he just turns into a
little [ __ ] yeah yeah because we're
friends right
we've known each other for years well i
get it man my bad dude i'm so sorry you
know and he puts him in his place
and so in the turn of events because
tongsu put uh chun-sook's
boss in jail and
tunsuk now you know and and like the
[ __ ] war
is about to happen yeah and they've got
to come to a head and [ __ ] talk about
this [ __ ]
right and why don't you lay this scene
out like where where it's going where
where they meet oh so they met not in a
karaoke spot but it was a
it was a club like it was a club so this
is like
the iconic thing that everybody
remembers from this film right and
specifically there's just
one line that he says that everybody
always quotes
because at this point there they have to
handle this right
and there's a line that was said
earlier in the film that we forgot to
mention which is basically saying
it goes back to this uh the idea of the
turtle
and uh the olympic swimmer yeah it's
like
i'm just born to do this like this is
who i am this is my life situation right
gangsters do what gangsters do there's
there's you're asking what we're told we
just do what we're told that's what it
is
and so they that line comes back in this
moment where they're having this little
gangster meeting right
and he sits over there and he's
basically giving him an ultimatum
right yeah which doesn't really sit well
with him because this is back
going back to his feeling of what am i
you're a little [ __ ] and you're
literally
what you say yeah yeah why do i have to
do exactly what you tell me what to do
but you see chung's demeanor
yeah of a friend is a friend yeah
which is what he's done throughout the
whole film you know except for what he
did in the beginning which we already
talked about that's probably
the catalyst to why their friendship
fell apart at that point right
because he didn't say hey he just said
do you want to die instead of that
and that planted the seed of hate in his
head like i don't know what our
relationship is
going back to that scene though after he
goes
right and then he lets go and backs down
right and then chintok leaves
tongsu looks in the mirror right looks
at him and he says
says the same thing yeah and you can see
him
wanting to be chunsok in the mirror and
to say the same thing at him which
culminates to this scene right
here exactly right he's waited his whole
life to say this to him
exactly and so he's basically kind of
being very elusive about the advice but
he knows what it means right
he goes hey like hawaii's really nice
right now you know you should probably
go there for a little bit until all the
stuff dies out
and he says the famous line that
everybody quotes in this film he goes
so he's like why don't you go to hawaii
like
why do i gotta do what you tell me to do
if you're so [ __ ] scared why don't
you go
and like the acting in that like he
takes his time and he's just like
putting his fingers through his forehead
and he's thinking he's getting the
[ __ ]
courage to say this to chun suk's face
and he says it like a [ __ ] man
yeah he's gonna but it's about his
[ __ ] life too
yeah the offer is like yo live go to
go go to hawaii or take your chance and
get finally get that chance to stick it
up to chunzo
yeah and he [ __ ] sticks it to ginseq
yeah
hawaii and that line just stuck with me
i'm like
[ __ ] man like it's it's it's his almost
like coming of age moment
one of his biggest [ __ ] mistakes ever
the worst mistake he could have made
because he's allowing this chip on his
shoulder
to guide all of his life choices yeah
and it's
it's actually [ __ ] him up because
everything that he thinks that he wants
throughout his life is nothing that he
needs right right
so it's this validation that he keeps
searching for some this from this
specific individual that he doesn't need
to gain because
he is just you're just my friend you had
it bro yeah
you had it he was your [ __ ] friend
man
you guys are you guys listening to this
love your [ __ ] friends
goddammit like their relationship it's
there's so many layers to this part
right and
this is what i love about this film so
much it's not a the film isn't
a gangster film it's about friendship
friendship loyalty
right seeing like people who
consistently think that the grass is
greener on the other side
right right and it's also about
circumstances like some people can't
fight their cir
they are just who they are and they have
to accept it right and there's one
character
where he is specifically putting himself
in these situations that he doesn't have
to be in this chip that he has
on his shoulder right which i see a lot
one of my cousins
remind me of tongsu so much right
and i feel sorry for him so all the time
and i see his behavior he's the black
sheep in the family
and he has these similar behaviors that
i see in this character all the time
it's because he's always looked at what
everybody else had wanted with somebody
else that rather than appreciating what
he had right here
yeah right and then you have somebody
like uh likes hang pek
who's this innocent character you know
he just wants to be everybody's friend
he wants to be happy
but he sees things everything through
such an innocent lens right and you had
the gangster character
where he looks up to him and he wants to
be him so it's just a circle [ __ ] of
just disaster
you know guys like
you might not even understand this movie
like because
it's in saturday yeah like it's in a
different dialect of korean by the way
we didn't even mention that but there's
a beauty to it too
and so
chun suk hears why don't you go to
hawaii
and he just right [ __ ]
okay [ __ ] but
you could see him thinking through it
and accepting this is
[ __ ] it right okay i'll go
with a smile on his face as a friend
i'll do what you say
right and then tong suzanne is like
right no
no conflict and he's walking out the
door
and the [ __ ] knife is waiting for him
yeah the whole gang is ready to kill him
and then what's he say he's like uh it's
his father's memorial a memorial
today yeah so i don't know but the way
he says it in saturday
is like this nice kind of like friendly
way it's just like this tonal kind of
thing
yeah they let him go and when he
when chunzo gets to his car the sign is
dropped
when he drops a cigarette and like
something that you they probably spent
all the budget on in this scene was like
this
crazy crash c and like [ __ ] mayhem
and they [ __ ] julius caesar the [ __ ]
out of tongsu and they kill him and the
crazy thing is this is the saddest part
of the film
is right when he's about to leave he
goes
how far is the airport from here
so he's he's going to go to hawaii he's
going to go to hawaii
he had his moment he thought about it
thought about it he goes
i'm going to go to hawaii something
something in his heart
right maybe it's because he had that
moment where he got to
man up he had what he needed and now
he's like i can go to hawaii now
i'll just wait it out so he yeah he asks
he goes how far is the
how far is the airport and the person's
like the airport
and then right when he's about to go the
cigarette drops he gets
stabbed up like a [ __ ] like it's
just non-stop guys
just trigger warning if you're cringy to
that like that like i think
over 30 times dad said later on in the
film
right and um i i mentioned this too like
when you watch a movie where someone
gets shot or even a marvel movie people
get shot and it's just like
move on right imagine captain america
taking a sashimi knife right into red
skull's heart yeah
and so you know i mean well thanos did
that to iron man right because there's a
[ __ ] emotional thing in film in
cinema wins you stab someone
the audience feels [ __ ] something
visceral dudes
movies was made were made for that [ __ ]
yeah this is uh
this moment too when you guys watch this
film like
the the person that's stabbing him is
obviously like a newbie member in that
group right
his dues he's paying his dues so he's
doing this hit
and he's stabbing up tongsu and tongsu
is actually looking at him directly in
his eyes
and he's like you're done go home yeah
you know you do it you did it all right
you did a good job so he's still doing
the whole like
i get it you do it go home this kid's
like terrified this is his first like
probably murder that he's ever done
yeah but just that moment he's looking
into that kid's eyes he's almost like he
sees himself in him
right yeah he goes you did what you had
to do go home now
and he just dies in the rain in a pool
of his own blood
it's just mison scene that's what you
call it in film school
in that moment i was like [ __ ] man yeah
i remember watching that
film um like for the first time and then
yeah i watched it a few times after
but that scene always stuck with me it
made me so depressed
right and it's just because he's a he's
not even a victim of his circumstance he
put himself there
it's the thing we talked about earlier
like when we're talking about like our
dads or whatever it's the
self-destructive natures like
when they're trying to do something good
they just
the [ __ ] pride ego han whatever the
[ __ ] you want to call it
you know like so i was mentioning my
cousin earlier and the reason why i see
that character and i see my cousin and
you know our our relationship to now
isn't that great because of how he
behaves yeah i i heard through my other
relatives that he's doing a lot better
now right
but our relationship became really bad
because of his behavior like that yeah
um
it's hard for me to talk to him because
i get angry when i see him like i get
infuriated because he has done so much
stupid and [ __ ] up [ __ ] now that i
know as a as as a christian man
my heart should forgive but then my
blood boils when i see him
you know so just to put it in
perspective he and i grew up very
different right
i was the kid that grew up in a bad
neighborhood in a bad circumstance
right and what i i never understood
about people who glorify people who grew
up poor
or in bad situations you're trying to
imitate this life i
i didn't want to be poor i don't want to
be in this
[ __ ] neighborhood you think i want to
do that i didn't want to see
when i was when i when my parents were
rebuilding their store right
the there was nice that we had i
couldn't stay at home by myself so i was
with my parents
i think i was like seven or eight that's
the first time i saw somebody get gunned
down you know i mean
these are not things i wanted to see and
so when i would see somebody look in my
life and they would hear these stories
and they're glorifying it it's like
listen i'm not even a gangster or a thug
i was just a kid in a poor neighborhood
and i didn't want to see these type of
things
but this kid was so weird this is my
cousin
he always found trouble
he had a mom and dad just like i did
happy family whatever his father worked
in the prison system everything else
right
worked there good dude whatever moved
into a very nice
quiet neighborhood but he always but i
would always hear some from his
from my aunt like yo he's in trouble
again he got kicked out of school he had
a gun i'm like
a gun [ __ ] why do you have a gun the
[ __ ]
you live in the nicest neighborhood what
the but he would specifically
choose to be in these bad situations
because he wanted to prove something to
somebody yeah
and it was something that he didn't have
to do
right and this is coming from somebody
who grew up in the neighborhoods that he
was traveling to to hang out
you're driving 30 miles to this
neighborhood so you could be something
that you're not
damn bro
you're commuting to be a gangster
exactly wow
a gangster community
holy [ __ ] how dedicated of a human being
are you right that you would do and i'm
like sitting here looking at him like
you're dumb
you are [ __ ] stupid like some of the
situations that i got into when i was
younger was because i
it's not that i didn't have a choice per
se but it's just what i grew up around
yeah you didn't have that yeah and you
actively
sought it out and so throughout his
whole life he had this issue
of seeking for other people's approval
and he still does it till this day
because you know i follow him through
some social media stuff until this day
everything that he says
out of his [ __ ] mouth is to seek the
approval of somebody else
yeah so this is why he never could
develop real friends
throughout his whole life never just
building and
creating an identity not like who he
really is so he would be around exactly
so just like tongsu
he would be around all these like people
these gangsters because
he was trying to emulate a life that he
was he was the olympic swimmer he wasn't
the turtle
right and so when i see tongsu i reminds
me of my cousin and it's so [ __ ]
pitiful it makes me
sad looking at that human being and so
eventually with my cousin like he got
into a bunch of trouble he's cleaning
himself up now he's doing a lot better
he's going to school he's he's doing
well
but it took him he wasted like 33 34
years of his life yeah
it's like why did you do that you didn't
have to do this
and so the one of the hardest things
that he had to come to terms with was
that he didn't have friends
right i'm like thomas has no friends too
he's exactly like that
and so he would he in fact rejected his
friends yeah
the people that mattered to him the most
that cared about him the most
he pushed away yeah and the people that
he kept around him were people that used
him
only for what he could do for them so i
told him too i was like you know what
the saddest thing about you is
like you don't even know these people
that you're around you're their [ __ ]
i was like they only have you around
because when they ask you to jump you
ask them how high
yeah you're the little [ __ ] that's why
they have you around
you're not their friend you didn't earn
their respect they don't respect you at
all
if you died tomorrow they wouldn't shed
a [ __ ] tear and you don't even
understand that
right and so when i see tong so i see my
cousin it makes me so sad i think a lot
of us have to realize maybe we're all a
bunch of sun techs man
like that's why it's in santa's
be like hey like you might have been in
some fights you might have so have i
you know but like realize you're just
like me we're we're not actual kang pez
we're not there
that's all my dad and my [ __ ] my
youth faster
yeah they look at me like sangtek they
meet like
they're just like you know how i told i
told you how that pass was so proud of
me that i didn't beat up that kid
it was like that for me i always watch
this movie and think about how
that pastor would tell me look me and
your dad we talk about it he won't tell
you
he's like but me and your dad talk and
we're so proud you're not like us
yeah he said because you're a good kid
and you're smart too and you're using it
like the way you can
that's what dad would never tell you
that in that moment that's why i
resonated that in that part in the scene
when um
uh [ __ ] the chang boss what's his
name
uh yeah when he was grabbing chun suk's
cheek
and he goes like what does your dad do
yeah and he starts beating the [ __ ] and
he goes like who told you that i was
[ __ ] proud of that [ __ ] yeah it's the
same situation like who told you that i
was proud of being poor
yeah like growing bigger these shitty
situations these are just life
experiences that i get to talk about
it's not just my life exactly and so
when i see some like kids they do this
and they imitate these lives
of glorifying stuff that they're not a
part of it's like
people are just this is the life this is
their circumstance
so what are you imitating right now we
want to be
you yeah we want to grow up with money
we want to grow up knowing how this
system works
we are just a product of our environment
that's it yeah so you have a leg up in
life and you're choosing to ignore it
because you're
that's one thing the grass is always
greener on the other side you know and
like
i i haven't there's probably american
stories like that that shows
like suburban kids getting into mess or
whatever but like
damn this movie really shed that light
like openly very well through tongsu
a character like tongsu so like i don't
know like
if you guys probably have friends you
can relate with between these
four characters you'll see yourself like
this such great story
telling you like you'll see yourself
your friends in either tongsu
you know or whatever like that's why the
storytelling of this is just
so well done i wish you guys got just
watch it i mean there's a there's a
chingu2 that came out years later that
sucked
but sucked it sucked it was all about
the [ __ ] swagger and the k
drama and the fight scene i just hated
that [ __ ] but
you know at the end of this film it gets
really sad because uh he actually
actually does go to hawaii
because you know he murders tongsu it
was
pretty crazy it was in broad daylight in
public it was a huge thing huge
investigation so he had a lead to hawaii
sad part about this is that he murdered
his friend and he had to live with the
guilt
and so he gets caught on purpose
it causes a [ __ ] crazy scene cuts up
all the waiters
cuts himself so when the police find him
this [ __ ]
compete going out like a kang pa arms
bleeding like a [ __ ] and this
girl is like trying to like
wrap him up and she runs the police and
this motherfucker's
drug just chugging chugging that alcohol
and like that guilt almost trying to
kill himself yeah he's trying to kill
himself
and he wants to get caught and so cuts
too
he's he's in he's in prison and
uh tongsu's father is talking to him
right
the the uh what's that called when you
you can talk to somebody and jump but
why my
glass the glass thing yeah tongsu's
father's like
i don't believe you did it you didn't do
it i know you didn't you were such a
good friend i had considered you a son
right and it's cutting between him and
their class clown
a lawyer for him got a lawyer for him
paid the prosecutors
did all the bribes right the politicians
put it right his defense
this this character comic relief through
and through but still like
here's here's the problem like chung ho
is being the friend the way he
thinks he should be a friend to chun-suk
yeah but chun suk's not asking for this
either
yeah he's not looking for a way out this
goes back to
the conversation they had when like yo i
ran away from home and my uncles my dad
didn't do [ __ ]
they didn't punish me and if they did i
would have known better right
and he's just blank listening to to this
information
his the guy who murders father doesn't
believe he did it and his friend is like
telling him you're out
you got this you know you're free and
he's blank
he's [ __ ] just speechless just taking
it or whatever
then it cuts to the court scene and then
they lay out the case
and he confesses he [ __ ] confesses
of his crimes he says i did it i told
him to do it
i knew these people yeah it was all part
of it
and everyone's shocked the crowd is
shocked
the [ __ ] prosecutor's shocked the
judge is shocked everyone's like what
the [ __ ]
yeah right and he
it goes back um to the visiting
whatever recorders and sang texts there
to visit him
and he's signing in and they say the
relation to
the prisoner chain and slow
cool yes
that scene is so sad and it's also very
cool because
the you know you could tell us how tech
is devastated you know because he's
trying to question
why did you do it and then why did you
do it in the sense of why did you kill
him and then also why did you do it
isn't why did you admit to the murder
right well the beautiful part is like
they get 10 minutes right
and the first part they're going through
an
awkward talk but they just keep hey come
on come on
we don't have time for this yeah they're
just catching up in life and they're
just he's just being there as his
[ __ ] friend you know like his only
friend
yeah my sister's getting married and
he's like oh [ __ ] i thought i was gonna
get it
what the [ __ ] how are you gonna get here
in prison and they're just hamming it up
he's being his
[ __ ] friend it's like i'll be back
i'll come and see you again
yeah saying that kind of [ __ ] i mean
this is my only gripe is that it does a
cross
fade and all of a sudden just crying
yeah he's like why'd you do it
i i would have edited a little
differently to say the time has passed
and now it's like the last 10 minutes
but
um it's the last minute and he finally
just
kind of just asked him straight up right
yeah let's do it
because it's embarrassing because that's
not what gangsters do
it's like it's like gangsters aren't
supposed to be embarrassed
like i choose to be embarrassed it's
like he chose to
punish himself because of the way his
uncles his dad
all the other kang pez never punished
him
the system now isn't going to punish him
he's going to get away with it he's born
in brett kanpur he's like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] this is
the only way it's over
yeah and he confess
to it he's like because conquest
shouldn't be humiliated yeah
and humiliates himself he did it [ __ ]
my way
yeah it's so good yeah this
these so good and then fade out to white
and they go back
to the olympic swimmer and the turtle
and the turtle
the natural and the guy who has to
really train to get there
oh [ __ ] out in the ocean and they're
swimming as little kids
but what did he remember about that
debate in the first place
that tongsu knew the turtle would win
and chun suk agreed with tongsuk because
they're
he's his friend he was on his side yeah
the innocence you know and like chun suk
was just always on tungsu's side he's
just if he just tongs
knew he wasn't his rival he wasn't his
competition he was his [ __ ]
friend
and that's why this [ __ ] this whole
thing is called chingu dude it's not
called
it's called it's called it's about
friendship and those relationships
you know that's that's crazy too it's
like tongsu just
saying situation is so sad he had
everything
you know he just chose not to see it he
couldn't see it
he was loved he had friends he
he could have studied if he wanted he
was just [ __ ] up just because he was
following toon sock
chunks [ __ ] up because he wasn't made
to study
yeah he was a smart [ __ ] kid you know
and then he kind of matured
later in life yeah after all the damage
was already done right
and then now he's now like him trying to
be this good
guy right for his friends it doesn't
translate anymore because the damage is
already done
because when that was necessary it
wasn't done at that time yeah and so now
the damage is he can't even see it now
he's just like
i don't get this guy like we're friends
right we're friends yeah i mean i mean
that that bathroom seam is
is the most memorable because that is
trauma
right it [ __ ] him up for the rest of
his life rest of the movie and
it speaks a lot like about us too right
like sometimes we act on resentment and
it's resentment from when i was
[ __ ] 19 years old what the [ __ ] was i
thinking about when i was 19.
yeah not the [ __ ] i'm thinking about now
why am i worrying
like a 19 why am i resenting like a 19
why am i
hurting or even younger kind of things
like it it's blatantly showing out like
what friends like when when chun song's
telling
is hang tech like friends don't say
sorry to each other
yeah meanwhile tongs was just like
either waiting for an apology or having
to say an apology
you know he just doesn't [ __ ] get the
friendship that he had with chunzak
tragedy it's such a tragic story yeah
but this is what i mean by like really
like really good films like it makes you
think about stuff in your own personal
life even if you haven't really even
gone through it right yeah and so
sometimes too when
when when i watch a film and it's very
few and far between lately where i've
seen a lot of films where i really
really enjoy
and i always go back to films that i i
though the why to why i like these films
is because it makes me feel like i'm in
these characters positions
a lot you know like things tie so well
together
and i think nowadays because films um
because of like
a lot of like uh cg graphics
explosions or everything there's no
nuance yeah you can get away with a lot
of these things without having to have a
good story
i think that's why a lot of people don't
like marvel films because
if you weren't a marvel fan before and
you don't have nostalgia to kind of tie
these pieces together
they don't know what the [ __ ] is going
on they're like none of this makes sense
yeah
it's just another lord of the rings
exactly
like none of these stories makes sense i
don't get what's going on so i
understand because uh one of my personal
friends he's he's a [ __ ] film buff
he hates marvel films because he's never
grew up with marvel and so he's watching
he goes how did they expect me to know
this stuff
yeah this shit's a [ __ ] this is so
stupid like i don't get this [ __ ] this
none of this [ __ ] makes sense he goes
the only one
that kind of made sense that you don't
need to watch is logan yeah
he goes like you don't need to watch it
because it's you know it's
you're basically it's a story about you
know logan and his life falling apart
you know and then try to find meaning
towards the end of his life so he goes
like i can
i can see that i can get that he goes
the other films he goes i don't know
what the [ __ ]
happened because you have to start
believing in aliens and then like okay
so then there's a stone
okay so then there's this okay yeah
exactly so it's like the reason why we
like these films because we grew up with
it yeah so we already there's nothing
that needs to be explained
yeah so but when somebody sees it with
fresh eyes it's like yo what the [ __ ] is
this stupid film
should we explain saturday too like
so if in korea it's not really a i guess
it's kind of a dialect right but it's
country country talk
it's like uh it's not like in in terms
of
southern talk in america because you can
still understand what they're saying
they just have a little bit of a
southern drawl i would think it's more
like
us americans trying to understand irish
people
it's english but they're like what they
have their own slang their own like yeah
all that [ __ ] so it's like it's almost
like that like if you're korean you
understand what they're saying but it's
yeah it's different
and it's it's got a cadence it's got a
dance
it sounds tonal yeah like japanese but
it's
it's just straight fantastic there's
also like um they curse really well in
it
yeah so so my mom used to speak in us
hatudi a lot
so a lot of the curse words that i know
is actually like country slang
which i didn't know you know i don't
know these things i'm not questioning
this stuff as a kid
and then there's also uh like chebudo
which is like jejudo
like korean language which you think is
hard to understand
i don't understand a [ __ ] word like i
don't understand
anything like their words are completely
different it doesn't sound
like i think like for example for us dog
means like
kangaji yeah and i think they're just
like kansenge or something like that
it's like a different color i think my
hair money spoke that [ __ ] she saw
she spoke some [ __ ] or ass korean yeah i
just like what the [ __ ] but i understood
her because i grew up with it yeah
like my mom's side they're they're all
saturi my dad's side is pretty solo and
but man i get jealous of my cousins
because they all speak saturday yeah
like [ __ ] i wish i spoke it like that
that [ __ ] sounds like some country bumpy
but i like i hate the way that sounds
dude because that's how my grandpa
swallowed right so when he would ask for
stuff you go you go vocal
what'd you say i'm like what the [ __ ]
are you saying right now speak korean
bro
speak some [ __ ] korean guy yeah
i was like what is this yeah another
note too is like the
the school teachers they remind me of
my [ __ ] church pastors oh yeah for
sure
like you're not really [ __ ] but because
of your authority
you can [ __ ] do this [ __ ] to me yeah
you know i mean i told that story before
about those three pastors who
who [ __ ] shaded me out of a thousand
bucks
if i explain to you what they look like
physically it's like
these [ __ ] [ __ ] pudgy as soft as
fish looking [ __ ] care bear
looking [ __ ] like
sometimes i wish i could have brought up
my hunt like i'll
[ __ ] punch you in your goddamn face
to these pastors you know so funny
they just like took it so muriel is
watching this k drama right now right
and she could sense me getting irritated
because there's this one character
that is a ceo of this company that's
[ __ ] over his
his stepdaughter right and he has that
korean
how does she look to his face right and
i'm looking at him and
as i'm watching this i don't know what's
going on i'm getting angry
and i was like look at this guy's
[ __ ] face i mean it's like why are
you cursing so much i was like he just
has that [ __ ] face
that i saw at every church where this is
[ __ ] talked down to me stupid little
[ __ ] bald ass [ __ ]
like bro if i didn't know what the [ __ ]
you were like it's just
kicking your goddamn [ __ ] teeth yeah
you know like
i think that's one of those things like
i go back to that
old kkk pastor like so chun seok
tells tong tek like don't start a fight
unless you're gonna finish it
it's like and if you start a fight like
beat him
yeah hurt him until he's a [ __ ] yeah
until he's begging for mercy
that old kk youth pastor told me the
same thing
he's like there's no mercy in
in l.a and koreatown you beat them until
they're crying
he said he beat someone until his teeth
were out there was blood over and
he was holding up his hand while he's
punching with his face he said i was
trying to knock him out man he wouldn't
knock out
and he said this guy was just sitting
there like with no teeth like
and he's like and i just kept beating
him until he fell asleep
and he's like that's how you do it
that's how we did it i never did [ __ ]
like that's funny you know and i was
like okay i'm santech
yeah i was like and i told this a long
time ago i think it was on a jk news or
something but i think a lot of the kids
didn't understand
it's because i must hunted too right
yeah but it doesn't mean
that the older hyungs weren't giving me
gangplay advice yeah like we didn't see
some [ __ ] and have to
be there with them yeah it would suck
you know i remember too it's like
because i was a big kid and i was always
like the bigger kid in the group so they
always wanted me to fight right
whether it was fight somebody new in the
group or they would want me to they
would just put me out there
they would put me in really bad
situations but one of the biggest advice
that they always gave me was this they
goes
when you beat somebody when we're
throwing down and you're fighting
somebody they always said this [ __ ] and
they used to creep me out
but i understood they said if you're not
beating them
like [ __ ] them up to try to kill them
they're going to kill you first
and so what that means is like you can't
punch somebody thinking that you don't
want to send them to the hospital
yeah because that's not what they're
thinking about when they're trying to
hurt you
yeah and that was like the scary thing
for me you know in my mind after saying
this [ __ ] i'm like yeah that's right
after when i went away i'm like
oh my god these people are crazy
you know but that was their advice but
it did save my ass a lot too but that's
it kind of goes with that line of like
you you're either about the [ __ ] or
you're not i wasn't about this stuff
you know but i just remembered them
telling me that i'm trying to act all
hard and [ __ ] i'm like yeah cuz that's
exactly what you're supposed to do
and i walk away i'm like oh my god
oh these people are crazy
i'm not gonna fight anybody yeah just
leave us
okay
yeah just leave me alone
yeah like uh uh when you know in like
tacoma too like i get those kind of
hyungs man
like who put me in a situation to fight
my [ __ ] friends dude
you know like why are we doing this they
fight yeah they just wanted us to
[ __ ] cockfight and make us fight each
other and [ __ ] and
you know we grew up on another [ __ ] or
whatever but
man in the ugliness of every time we
talk about
[ __ ] up [ __ ] like the the friendship
that this movie portrays though dog
like like the the the meaning of like
forgiveness and unconditional love
through not saying having to say sorry
to a friend who will
you know who doesn't have to you know be
there to forgive because he's already
loves you anyway kind of yeah like we
experience the fullest
of those things it's so weird if you're
not korean
or korean-american
it's hard to explain how [ __ ] up they
would treat you but love you
yeah at the same time last week he gave
a motorcycle
this week he like bought me lunch and he
took me to the arcade
it would be like some weird [ __ ] where
they would [ __ ] you up right they would
beat you up
but somebody else will come and try to
[ __ ] with you and they go hey holy i do
that to him
that's for real because like when like
my young's rivals [ __ ] with us
oh they get so pissed at those guys i
was like but honestly last week you guys
beat me up ten times
like that's just me holy eye
knock out his teeth don't you dare touch
his balls that's reserved for my foot
it's like thanks i guess oh [ __ ] man
korean culture is so [ __ ] weird like
that you know a part of me is like
i understand that i'm not gonna do that
right but a part of me is gonna be like
they're kind of missing out a little bit
yeah they were there for me like
seriously i
i really see it as like the my friends
that are younger than me
have no idea the experience we grew up
under yeah they have no idea what that's
like
i feel like that's part of like the
korean american millennial experience
probably because it's over you don't see
that [ __ ] they don't do that
i actually got really sad thinking about
how
you know our experience with uh
korean-american culture is very unique
and the next generation's not going to
have this like for example tahar money
that makes panchan
they're not going to have that right you
know what i mean they're not going to
have the the korean market the ajimah
making panchayat that doesn't speak any
english this next generation won't have
that
you're gonna get it from costco bro
you're gonna get vons or safeway or
something
right kimchi man you're gonna get it
from a [ __ ] place in silver lake from
a white lady
that's selling kimchi for 17 for a
[ __ ] little mason jar
i mean like just for example we look at
the japanese who've been here since 1900
right and now there's fourth fist
japanese people living in torrance
yeah like they look straight japanese
but they're straight american
yeah straight up you know i get scared
uh
a little bit of of like our culture
dying
you know that's why i'm very particular
about
preserving my culture right while i live
in this country right you know my kids
will learn
they'll they'll speak korean better than
i speak korean and it's important to me
you could marry whoever the [ __ ] you
want culture to me has nothing to do
with the way your eyes are your skin
whatever it's it's the tradition the
language the food
that's where it all lives for me right
he's going to come and call you dad
you're like my name is
like hey dad
who's that it's alpha you know yeah so
you know when i when i have kids i'm
it's very important to me like you could
marry whoever
right but i think for them i would ask
them it's like marry whoever
you know find that love but i would ask
for you and you and the person that you
married to actually learn about our
culture
learn about our food how we behave what
we do and also learn the language
it's important it's important to me yeah
i'm not going to dictate who you're with
but if
if now that you know the language and
you know our culture the person that
you're with whether
they're white black mexican asian indian
whatever it is
i would like them to know the language
and the culture too yeah that's it yeah
man like
um i think that's one of the cool things
about growing up in tacoma you got
friends like dan
he's half white half korean all about
korean culture what was his great korean
name
dad fisher she's fish yeah no i mean
like
i grew up with a friend halfway half
korean all about the korean culture he
looked like kangta
if he was white grew up with us and [ __ ]
i mean like
um he was our captain growing up
you know he was my brother's best friend
they were [ __ ] tight
and man um one time i was with my
crush inside someone's house like queer
bit um
and she was coming out of the bathroom i
was going in and washing my hands
and my friend his name is sean he goes
oh
ed and sue me are in the bathroom
together right oh my
god i got [ __ ] [ __ ] blocker dude but
i got so
mad now mind like i said he's half white
half korean
he's black belt taekwondo star baseball
player in a high school
he's the [ __ ] man like and for some
reason i walked up to him and i sucked
him right in the chest because i was so
mad
and i saw his face i was like that's it
i'm gonna die
oh [ __ ] he grabbed me and he pulled me
into the same bathroom
and he goes look now we're both in the
bathroom why are you so angry man
what's wrong and then i don't know why i
started telling him what was going on at
home
and this [ __ ] guy man he gave me a
big hug and he started [ __ ] praying
for me man
how lucky are you like oh my god oh my
god this guy could have
ripped my head off yeah but he was like
look man like i love you
and my god loves you dude like don't be
angry and all this [ __ ] i'm just
crying in this he's like you know what
just beat me up
well a month later he passed away oh
really
monthly yeah how
like um
he he was born with like this really
weak heart
yeah crazy he was supposed to die when
he was like a year old
but by the time he's 15 like i said like
black belt taekwondo looks like kang
hot like good looking dude but half
white you know
um breakdancer first one i've ever seen
to do a windmill
yeah yeah man super talented baseball
star and he was at a taekwondo
tournament
and his heart gave out heart gave out
does his parents know about his heart
condition yeah they
always knew they never told us and there
was the kind of dude that [ __ ] lived
his life
that's crazy and he was like our captain
type yeah
it's so weird that i say that [ __ ]
because like our parents didn't teach us
we're just koreans and it's just in our
dna we followed this guy
yeah and he was my brother's best
[ __ ] friend
and like and that that was so rough
during that time
you know and then my brother became he
was like the arc
we started following my older brother
you know and
how did your brother deal with that [ __ ]
that must've been rough yeah that's uh
it was a rough time for him yeah he he
was pretty silent
i didn't hear him talk a whole lot yeah
he was a very silent guy and
came back from the [ __ ] navy as a
knockout artist
all of a sudden that's crazy you know
and so like
yeah like my brother that's his own
story like i don't want to tell honestly
but that was his best friend that was my
friend and
i i see that group of friends growing up
and to see
our chin suck type just die yeah out of
the blue and you always
you know when you when i hear that too
it's kind of like a big part of your
heart's always like
would that person be right now yeah you
know who would he be to us i swear to
god he'd be in mlb or in the ufc
yeah or a pop star or literally someone
or a doctor
yeah he just had endless potential and
it kind of sucks to you know my
well there was somebody in mar
elementary school my story is a little
different yeah especially because we
look up to this guy
but this guy uh i guess he had a he had
a heart condition too
he had an overgrown heart and he also
passed away i think in uh
he was like sleepwalking uh this is i
don't think is exactly what i mean
somebody will come with his heart
stopped i think his um his mom did or
his dad did
and so he was sleepwalking i don't think
they knew yeah uh i mean this is
in elementary school i found this out
but i if i look it through my adult lens
i'm pretty sure his mom didn't knew that
he was sleepwalking and they're like hey
what are you doing
you know and they kind of shook him
awake but that jolted him and it
causes something happened with his heart
but he had a heart attack and he died
and this was like in elementary school
and let me tell you something too like
the funny thing is is like me and my
brother actually got into a fight with
that kid
like a couple like a few months before
he passed away with him and his younger
brother
right you guys must have felt terrible
horrible no i did not
okay my story is a little different
but i remember it's because my brother
and i went to this place called cordio
taekwondo
and they were also they were like in a
robinson's taekwondo right let me tell
you some robinson's taekwondo and a
traditional korean spot are two
different things yeah
and so they were talking man [ __ ] this
is actually the fight this is a fight
that me and my brother both got into
with that family
and we [ __ ] their asses up just to
show you the difference between korean
taekwondo
like military tangsudo versus your
little
robinson's taekwondo and i remember the
olympics
my brother did like the spinning heel
kick and i remember i [ __ ] back
straight kick
kicked that kid in his stomach and he
[ __ ] flew because we did tournaments
we did sparring hardcore
not point contact like beating each
other's ass spin is to generate torque
not to get a point exactly it was
different back in the day
and so i remember i just [ __ ] back
straight kicked the living [ __ ] out of
this kid and i didn't know about that
dude's heart condition until later but
the kid passed away and like in his
sleep
younger brother he was fine damn yeah
yeah i mean like [ __ ] i don't know what
to
do
maybe that's why suck no i mean like uh
well to take it back like
even my friend like his mom like this is
99 so
mom buried him in his jingle jeans oh
wow yeah
and like the photos of us like when
we're all hanging out and [ __ ] so that
was like a
a good time and and like when i watch
the movie chingu and like see the
friendships
i go through and even the loss like um
as a korean-american like if you
understand that uncontrollable
emotion and passion and that's part of
you like and enacting on
your resentment or your words and like
and the tragedy behind
making such decisions yeah you gotta
watch this movie
you'll love it you'll [ __ ] love this
film i i don't know a single person who
ever watched chingu and didn't
either cry take something away from it
or just love the film and watch it again
yeah you know so if you guys ever wanted
to have like a step into korean cinema
and a
a good look into how like korean culture
and friendship and loyalty
um ching was a really great way to start
it's the film yeah place to start
they're like oh all korean people are
gangsters
it's a little more real yeah there's
consequences
well guys i hope you liked that episode
where we reviewed uh one of our favorite
korean films of
all time i hope you guys enjoyed that
maybe we'll do another one depending if
you guys don't like it
i'll probably still do another one sorry
but
uh genius brain podcast every thursdays
and sundays the topics are always random
you don't know what you're going to get
sometimes the film reviews sometimes
[ __ ]
i really do got to bring a box of
tissues because mario cried here
yesterday
[ __ ] crying in my podcast yeah i'm
gonna need that too
yeah and uh you can find ed at ed parkvp
find him on instagram follow him there
follow this journey then you'll see him
back on the podcast and we'll see you
all next time
peace peace go to hawaii